dix millions d'euros c'est le budget
attribué à la rénovation de la gare de
montigny le bretonneux construite il ya
37 ans elle draine près de 70 mille
usagers chaque jour des travaux coûteux
mais nécessaire selon la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines principal
investisseur avec la sncf il faut savoir
que ici sur saint quentin en yvelines la
gare juste au dessus on a près de 2000
mouvement de bus par jour on a 300
trains dont il y avait nécessité de
renforcer l'accessibilité d'améliorer la
visibilité est d'améliorer d'une façon
plus globale le confort des voyageurs
sur les 10 millions d'euros alloué 6
millions sont pour la salle des pas
perdus le reste va à la partie liaison
c'est à dire entre les gares ferroviaire
et routières les taxis et les voies
piétonnes le calendrier et on va dire
strictement respectées pourquoi parce
qu'il s'inscrit dans une opération
globale d'aménagement urbain des
interventions ultérieures sur les abords
sur le site où nous sommes sont aussi
programmés dans un horizon de deux trois
ans ce nouveau pôle mise sur le
transport multimodal avec par exemple la
location de véhicules électriques et de
vélo livraison prévue de l'ensemble de
la gare en mars prochain les commerces
réouvrir ont quant à eux au cours de
l'année 2013